[Music]
hey hi everyone welcome back to our
podcast and the series called High
School memories my name is Diora and
I'll be your host today so without
further Ado let's dive into today's
episode and embark on a great journey
together other get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired of course
today's topic will be about the impact
of social media on your friends let's
start if I am asked why I chose this
topic I chose that because this is the
reality that we face every day all
generations right young people adults up
to our grandparents well it is mostly
pronounced in teenagers from the moment
we wake up from the sleep until the late
hours at school in cafes at home and on
the street social medias are the main
and current thing empathized in teenager
for the reason that between the two
paths We Are Young to make the right
choice between the paths that have
positive components or the negative ones
presented to us by these social
networks first of all it is worth
mentioning all the positive impact
regarding social networks especially
these days in newspapers portals writing
and publication from all categories we
have Global support for the people
attacked in the wars that are taking
place in the world it isn't easy
encouraging
youth towards solidarity peace and
helping each other all over the
world we can do it right in photos and
posts we see children die crying old men
crying woman being violated and even men
dying for their country the WTH is aware
everyday to fight for International
Peace but also to give support and
social assistance to say stop violence
and pro
peace young man and woman have Flo to
climb mountain peaks around the world
where they publicly show the challenges
they have gone through to be where they
are it wasn't easy I swear this means
that all of us if we want we can
obtaining obtaining information in any
field that we need because in the past
this fact has presented a lot of
difficulty now we cannot call anyone
ignorant because there is research in
social networks it is very easy the
solidarity and organization of various
campaigns for disease such as cancer D
syndrome and autism where we are as a
society can make and become more aware
every
day has had a positive impact because
now parents are also investing in
advancement of their
children uh and have begun to support
them publicly Society in general but
even as a teenagers we try to support
and stay away from buling of course in
social networks every day we meet new
people
nationalities races Traditions religions
and new
cultures things that makes us closer
that makes us closer and more social to
have contacts and work with the whole
world the influence of well-known
athletes such as Leo Messi and Cristiano
Ronaldo who publicly show their
achievements and successes becoming
Idols for young teenagers especially
boys to be like them
as well as I consider the kitchen
businesses and fashion fashion is more
for girls but in the addition to the
positive sides we must also see the
other side of the coin the
negativity at the moment when I want to
start with a negative negative
impacts the first and the most pronoun
is the large amount of time spent on
social
networks since youth Left Behind the
person
the pursuit of their dreams jobs and
hobbies and that makes teenagers see
their dreams only from a screen and not
to fight to achieve them just imagine it
in social networks most publish what
they want us to see and not what it
really
is
success is published but not the
struggle in the sleepless nights luxury
is published but not the effort to get
there happiness is published but not the
tears that were shed before so not
everything we see is like that in
reality we know that the use of wild
language buing swearing and slander
through photos and writings where most
of them are ped with masks be uh hiding
behind fake profiles by means of the
language of hatred and offensive words
they send people into depression and
even commit
suicide wow teenagers happily play video
games but they are also harmful to their
mental and physical health The Limited
privacy of people the publication of
their private life residents and work
location is the reason why it is very
easy for people to know more about our
lives it isn't good for
us another reason for online bullying is
that people are justed by their physical
appearance lifestyle even though people
don't know the hardship of their of
others people's
lives all these
sentences facts and arguments were made
for one reason so that we can change our
mentality and the way of thinking about
things all of us can do it become
optimistic and take only positive
impacts and try to avoid negative ones
and use any social media for the battle
the change must start from
us we can't yet wait for others to do it
we need to
start thank you so much for joining us
on this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take care
this was me in this podcast and uh I
hope you liked
it uh we'll see this is not the end we
will see each other on other episodes or
next time take care
[Music]
bye